Notable developments
in the special counsel's
investigation of Donald Trump,
including word of yet
another subpoena
involving the former
president's finances.
According to notes that Evan
Corcoran took of his conversations
with his client.
Donald Trump, the former president,
wanted to fight the subpoena
that demanded
that he return
classified documents that he had no right
to have after his time in office.
Now, these notes taken
by Corcoran are providing
more insight into Trump's thinking
and his actions
around the time
the criminal investigation was launched.
And now
they sit
in the hands of the special counsel,
Jack Smith.
Joining us now is John Dean.
He was the White House
counsel for Richard Nixon.
And just like Evan Corcoran, John,
you testified
about your conversations with
President Nixon. So
as you listen to
what has been reported here in your mind,
why would there even be
dozens of pages of documents notes about
what to do with a lawful subpoena?
Shouldn't
that conversation
between attorney
and client be pretty short?
Well, I know Mr.
Trump in the past
has said
he was surprised
when his White House
counsel were keeping notes.
I didn't keep notes
when I was White House counsel,
and I didn't know
there was a taping system,
which fortunately was there.
But the immediate problem for
Evan Cochran is that he,
I think, did suspect that his client
was a little squirrely
and he didn't know
how things were going to turn out.
So he kept very detailed notes,
apparently down to as reported.
Such things as his facial expressions
during conversation.
Yeah.
I mean, it does seem to
suggest that Corcoran
had a sense that something was
was potentially going to come back
to and needed to be documented.
One of the sources
described Corcoran's notes
as, quote, overly detailed
Another source said
that some were surprised
that at that level of detail,
do you think that Corcoran
could have also been
trying to perhaps protect himself
I think there's a good reason to suspect
that's the case.
I think there's a
we don't know what's in the notes
at this point.
We know they are
where valuable enough to the prosecutors
that they went to court
and got a judge to say that.
It appears
that they're certainly evidence
to indicate that Mr.
Cochran's client, the president
or the former president,
was taking advantage
of that counsel to commit a crime.
And that's the exception
Which is breaching the privilege
which judges don't like to do.
That's a very sacred privilege.
So judges are very aware of it.
And it's a
But it's
very telling to us
as spectators in this this point
that we are seeing a case
that is being built
and there's judges
who are looking at this evidence,
see evidence of criminal behavior by Mr.
Trump.
Yeah, that crime fraud exception
was found by the judge in this case,
which is a very high bar typically.
Here's what sources close to former
President Trump are saying.
They're saying that
he was just asking
his lawyer, Corcoran, for legal advice
whether when he asked about
whether or not
they could fight the subpoena.
So if you're a prosecutor
and you're examining these notes,
how do you determine
what is the line between perhaps Trump
trying to obstruct
justice, asking
how to get out of a subpoena?
And Trump,
you know,
let's let's let's us
play devil's advocate.
Trump could have been playing devil's
advocate in that moment.
I think that is what his
his aides are suggesting here.
Well, as I piece together the reporting,
it appears what might have happened
is he might have
legitimately probed his lawyer,
but the lawyer
but he took the advice
his lawyer
gave him and turned around
and shared it with somebody else.
And they appear to have moved documents
and things of that nature.
Once the subpoena
arrived to try to avoid it
being fully uncovered and discovered
So that's the sort of thing
that these notes can tell us
and lead us to
have a better understanding of.
And that would show his criminal intent.
You know,
whether or not it's just willful
use of this material
or whether it's an obstruction,
it appears the obstruction case
is most prominent and strongest
at this point.
So there's another detail
that is very interesting
that we're learning
from The New York Times.
They're reporting that prosecutors
have also issued
a subpoena
about Trump's foreign businesses in seven
very specific countries
in China,
France, Turkey,
Saudi Arabia, Kuwait
and the United Arab Emirates.
And also Oman.
What does
does it say to you
that they are looking at these
deals, deals that date back to 2017,
meaning wild Trump was still president of
the United States?
Well, it's
in fact
that it
goes back
throughout his presidency is very telling
that they're looking to see
what he might have shared.
And I think there's
a good reason to do that.
What he shared of intelligence nature
we know he did it
well in the Oval Office
and they had to rush
declassify information when he gave
Ambassador Lavrov
clearly sources and methods
which was a troublesome thing.
But here
you know I thought my immediate reaction
when Kaitlan asked him at the town hall
you know
have you ever shared
any of this information with anybody?
The answer that most people
would have given was, of course I didn't.
This was national security information.
Trump's answer was, I don't recall.
That just doesn't flip.
It's not surprising
that the special counsel
is trying to find out
who in the world
was this man dealing with
and what might have been
an occasion
that he could have
shared this information
or what motive might have been
for the information?
Yeah.
I mean,
I think that speaks to a major question
that we still have,
which is the why of it all.
Why would he want to keep the documents?
What is the motive, as you just said?
But turning
to one of the other legal cases
that the former president
has been embroiled
in, this is dealing with AG and Carroll's
defamation
and sexual assault case against him.
It seems now that she is wanting
to amend
this case based on his comments
in that CNN town hall.
I want you to take a listen to this
They said he didn't rape her
and they didn't
I didn't do anything else either.
You know what?
Because I have no idea
who the hell she is.
But, Mr. President, can I ask.
They said, sir, don't do it.
This is a fake story,
and you don't want to give it
credibility.
One thing you go
one thing you did do in this.
And I swear and I've never done that.
And I swear to I have no idea
who the hell she's a
she's a whack job.
So what do you make of today's filings?
Are you surprised at all?
Not at all.
I think that
what was done was very thoughtful.
It wasn't a new case.
It was filed
it was filed against
the original complaint
that was done back in November of 2019.
That has been bouncing
around the courts over
who can represent Trump,
whether he because he was president
when he said that
the Department of Justice
should be involved in this.
And that has not been.
It's gone up to two court of appeals
and now it's back down
in the district court.
That's where she amended it.
It's back there
and it shows punitive damages.
It many of these issues
in the original case
have already been tried.
It's the same judge. He's very savvy.
He knows what's going on.
It was a brilliant move.
And I think Trump could end up
paying another five
or more million dollars
as a result of his loose lips.
Not not the only comment that he made
in that town.
Hall that could end up having
some real legal,
legal repercussions for him.
John Dean,
thank you very much for all of that.